you can drink the water okay let's do
one dry open on a swig how much but
that's okay we'll show the box as you uh
it's uh mmm Evian water conserving water
um
letters to a young contrarian why'd you
write this up by all means yeah wave it
more well I shall read because I was
invited to some of your viewers maybe
you two would given when they were young
I'm sure led us to a young code by
Ronnie Maria Rilke the read German a
poet who received these touching letters
from a young man who wondered if the
poetic life could be lived or was worth
leading and he replied and it's an
exquisite little book putting one's own
efforts rather in the shade but the idea
of Perseus books was to see if we could
do this again so for example you'll be
thrilled to hear Jesse Norman has
written letters to a young diva advise
students when somebody might want to
emulate her this leads to a young lawyer
I believe and then me for those who are
vaguely malcontented and might want to
transfer their discontent into some sort
of energy or perhaps into writing so
very tentatively because it marks my
definite accession into middle age you
don't get asked to write for the young
unless you've become old you have to
face it
I write to actually the people I write
to a real and they're my students in the
new school in New York where I teach
part-time and other students I've had in
Berkeley in other places so I always
have someone in mind
who's actually asked me a specific
question one of people you're right
about buckle havel why'd you include him
in the book and who is he for those who
are not familiar with him Ruslan Pavel
is the president now the Czech Republic
and he was the president of
Czechoslovakia before if it D federated
itself when it became again a free
country in 1989 with the collapse of the
Berlin Wall and of the the Stalinist
system and the reason why I take him as
an exemplary case is that he's a man who
organized a massive national and civic
resistance
completely non-violently completely
successfully just by writing and writing
ironically and teasingly about the
self-evident absurdity of the system he
was living under and incredibly it just
fell down you know and it was brought
down basically its exaggerating slightly
and it's a vaguely romantic way of
putting it is not really untrue it's
brought down by poets playwrights and
vests and and authors so the way that he
lived that life and made words into
weapons has always struck me as a
absolute fabulous 20th century story
Christopher Hitchens will be with us
till the top of the hour our phone lines
are open they are divided regionally and
if you're watching us overseas or in
Mexico and Canada 2 0 to 6 to 800 205
you refer to a man by the name of
Santiago Alvarez who you described as
the grand old man of Cubans Cuba cinema
film was the special medium of the Cuban
Revolution and as he assured us was
unfettered completely unfettered well he
said with a slight laugh there is one
thing that is not done no satirical
portrayal of the leader will be
permitted referring to Fidel Castro I
said quite simply that if the main
subject of Castro was off-limits then in
effect there could be no real satire or
criticism at all absolutely where we can
be charged you've got under learnings
and notes in the margin and so I've read
it thank you and it's your greed it's
quite short and very reasonably priced
and very nicely packaged the perfect
Thanksgiving and Hannaford gift I
already have to say this once
I'll keep showing the bottom I want to
ask you about the photograph - about yes
Santiago virus I believe is still with
us is it was the author of a lot of very
punchy colorful polemical Cuban films in
the early 60s the time when Cuba was
considered - very exciting a place not
and not just on the left and were a
large number of very very good film
directors were then more or less for you
to work anyway I went to Cuba in 1968 as
a young leftist
and I was very interested to see if the
claim was true the Cuban claim was our
revolution is not there to be like man
said to him or Stalin it's going to be
different it won't he won't end up a
kind of grey conformist regimes and all
of us were excited that we thought this
could be true and I what I'm writing
about here for my younger audiences you
know what what to do when you encounter
disillusionment in a sense and we had we
had I was very thrilled with like a
seminar with Santiago viruses films I'd
seen it I said well you know talk more
about it and then he said well we're
very free here it was very unfettered
there's only one limitation you know you
don't make jokes about the leader and I
said well the mr. Castro seems to be a
kind of big factor in this revolution so
if you're leaving him out he's off
limits that's not a detail is it and
people began to look at me as if I was
being um uncooperative or you know
disloyal and it was a sort of early
warning to me because unfortunately now
I mean the Cuban cinema is there is
still a Havana Film Festival people do
still go to it but all the life in Cairo
has gone out of Cuban cinema and indeed
of the Cuban Revolution in tragedy as
you well know there's a meeting going on
today with the Karl Rove senior advisor
to the President and some of Hollywood's
executives what role do you think
Hollywood can play in what we're seeing
in Afghanistan and elsewhere in the
world good grief
not I hope I'd like to think I have an
answer to any question you could
possibly ask me I haven't thought about
this one but I I can't think that
Hollywood can be not sure by the way let
me go back to your words and then we'll
open it up to calls you conclude your
book by saying this may summarize the
essence of the book the high ambition
therefore seems to me to be this that
one should strive to combine the maximum
of impatience with a maximum of
skepticism the maximum of hatred of
injustice and irrationality with a
maximum of ironic self-criticism
this would mean really deciding to learn
from history rather than invoking it
it's not bad let's go Cobblepot
so what's the message well the message
is to try and live your life as if you
were a free person
that you didn't have to wonder what
anyone else's opinion was that you were
that you should take the risk of
believing that if you're the only person
who thinks what you think that that
still might well mean that you were
right in fact though that loneliness
often makes people wonder because
perhaps out of modesty they feel well if
I feel this way never else doesn't maybe
I'm crazy or maybe I'm maybe something
they know that I don't try to encourage
people not to think like that you're
nervous sometimes on church shows I'm
sure intolerant shows as well people
will often say well as soon as I was
just saying and as I be not quite agree
and they're nervous they don't want to
speak in their own voice they would ever
cut quite come out and say this is what
I think what I'm trying to give people
the the confidence to do in other words
is to not only think that even if you're
the only one who thinks that it could be
true but you imagine that actually if
the majority thinks one thing it's more
likely than not to be wrong where was
the picture taken the picture was taken
in a studio in Georgetown earlier this
year just by the canal how many taxes
cigarette to smoke it's a shameful
admission it depends on how long the day
is really I mean if I have a long day I
can go three packs which is you know
it'll it'll kill me
I don't put advice to the young or any
other kind in my book but if there's
anyone watching who is young who does
smoke if they can stop now they really
ought to try would you if you could okay
I would I think to implementing probably
aren't meant to do it and some people
are and some writers I think have
relationship with both alcohol and
nicotine that's creative destructive but
it's somehow it's part of one's cursed
I'm one of those I can also handle it
but um play way I mean we mustn't get
too pious and depressing on a Sunday
morning but I Nathan if anyone's
thinking of taking it up definitely
don't Detroit good morning for
Christopher Hitchens morning good
morning hi um I have a son who I spent
an hour on the phone with yesterday
arguing about what's going to happen to
the world
and he is probably personifying a lot of
that last paragraph and I wanted to know
really get on to this he says that the
crux of the situation is that no one has
any ethics anymore and that evil is
going to beat good and no matter how
much we try although he's very much in
favor of fighting injustice and
inequality and a very liberal person
he's got a real defeatist attitude right
now 23 medical school and I think he
kind of personifies the younger
generation right now and I'm very
worried well don't give up don't give up
so easily for one thing and for sure
don't give up on your own son maybe see
if I can encourage him and perhaps you
I'm presuming that by evil and good you
are you're referring to the current
clash okay I'll make that assumption
this may sound awful
but I found a certain sense of
exhilaration on September the 11th which
has not left me since I thought now here
if you want it is the enemy in
absolutely plain view all the things I
write about in my book intolerance
racism stupidity religious cult ISM the
refusals are think the refusal to allow
skepticism the the denial of reason
there at all it perfectly embodied and
symbolize with its consequences which
and its means are its ends what civilian
murder
filthy murderous attack on civil society
is inscribed in the means and the ends
the means are dead bodies they use they
used civilians to kill civilians if you
follow me if you who can imagine the
conditions on those planes in the last
minutes right I thought okay now I
absolutely know what side I'm on I don't
need the President to tell me and I hope
very few people did I've since then been
to Pakistan because I thought I'd better
have a look I've been to the Afghan
front because I thought I ought to I've
been to Kashmir where I think the next
war
we'll be if we're not careful about it
and I've come to the following
conclusion mr. bin Laden made an
absolutely horrific mistake when he did
what he did it's horrific in every other
sense - obviously as I've just said but
what he has done is now called for a
holy war against the Jews against the
Christians against of naturally the
secular world people like myself against
quite a lot of other Muslims and now not
many people notice this against Hinduism
as well no he's just made a billion
enemies in India furthermore by doing
what he did he derailed something that
was happening in Pakistan a very
horrible thing that was happening now
sort of keep using the word horrible but
I would I would say quite soberly that
within a year maybe less if the World
Trade Center had not been destroyed and
the other atrocities in Washington and
Pennsylvania had not occurred the
Taliban and its allies including
al-qaeda would have taken over Pakistan
Pakistan was being very rapidly
Charbonneau's through its military
oligarchy and the religious parties and
Muslim Jihad groups has been sponsoring
they won't get hold of the Pakistani
state now they work and they won't get
all of this nuclear weapons which they
were hoping to do and you hear all the
time that there's a lot of Muslim
opinion that favors must have been
Lardner thinks of as a hero but what can
you do for them they can't go and join
him in his cave even if they want you
they can't go back to the 15th century
with him we'll live in the desert with
him either what he demands of them is
literally impossible so there's
absolutely no chance that he can win I
mean you can exclude the possibility of
the victory of you it cannot happen and
I think it might be we might make some
quite good friends in loop in the battle
against it I would particularly
recommend making a friend of the secular
pluralist democracy of India which has
long been far too low on the United
States a list of countries to be well
connected with I think look forward very
much to cooperating with India and
repudiating tribalism communalism as the
Indians call religious sectarianism and
so you know I get up every morning
thinking what can I do today to join the
battle for and extend the battle for
secular pluralist democracy and
inconvenience and humiliate its first I
guess Christopher Hitchens who's also a
contributing editor for this publication
Vanity Fair this is where the December
issue looks like and inside he writes
for Patriots dream for Patriot Dreams
based on what the caller just brought up
will get a call from Dublin Ireland go
ahead please hello I'd like to say to
mr. Hitchens I enjoy his work very much
it's very kind of you thank you f thanks
very much I was wondering how you look
on mr. Clinton's or President Clinton's
administration being somewhat sleep the
wheel with regard to bin Laden I mean it
wasn't the first time the madness truck
what do you think was his fault well I
can refer to a chapter in my book about
mr. Clinton which the book has called
them no one left to lie to in case in
case you wonder what I think about him
in general what I think about him in
particular this chapter which is called
Clinton's war crimes is that he did one
of the one of the worst things any
president has ever done he used American
cruise missiles in a covert and
surreptitious decision that was taken
against the advice of most of his Joint
Chiefs and his intelligence chiefs and
diplomats ostensibly to bomb a terrorist
facility as they call it in Sudan but
actually in order to try and fool around
with public opinion on the day the
molecular Winsky was going back to the
grand jury it was as we say in
Washington a wag the dog moment he he
picked a target excuse me he picked a
target which he knew was not a military
facility that was actually the factory
making most of the pharmaceuticals and
medicines for Sudan gravely damaging the
fabric of that society he shot another
couple of missiles into what he thought
was Afghanistan if I one of them landed
in Pakistan accidentally revealing the
connection between the Pakistani army
and bin Laden but
cuz the missiles killed a couple of
Pakistani officers who had no business
being in a bin Laden camp but were
training infiltrators for Kashmir and
having made a complete fool of himself
having been exposed before the United
Nations as having hit the wrong target
for the wrong reasons in a shady week
where he was trying to avoid impeachment
she dropped the subject bin Laden
altogether it was a photo-op moment for
him had failed he was he then went on to
basically ignore the whole question even
though a great deal more was
accidentally disclosed about this
network and what it had in mind for us
Los Angeles good morning I'm sorry as
with everything else about his
presidency it wasn't just eight years
wasted it was it was eight years we
really ought to try and have back this
the most the most deplorable presidency
possible Los Angeles go ahead please hi
thanks for taking the call good morning
I do have a question for mr. Hitchens
but I'm curious did you not write a book
recently about Henry Kissinger I did
okay thanks for everyone mentioning all
my other books I'm thrilled how's it go
the trial of Henry Kissinger it's argues
that Henry Kissinger can and should be
brought within the ambit of law for
crimes against humanity and war crimes
how many books have you written in my
life I about twelve or so twelve
thirteen oh actually may sound conceited
I don't know
and some of them were pamphlets really
rolling books I mean the did full length
proper books about three collections of
essays or short sub books maybe about
another five or six going on I think sir
thank you patient sure um I guess such a
huge subject and there's so many things
that one would like to say and time is
so short but I guess briefly an answer
to Daniel Pipes question about what
could we do for moderates I think what
we could do is pay them I think it seems
a worldwide there's this struggle
between labor and people in power and it
doesn't really matter what religion what
nationality what age you know what time
in human history it's it's always there
and when we pay workers well they're
pretty happy and we get along
harmoniously and when we find we can't
pay workers well there's plenty of
trouble and the people in power will do
anything and everything
including sending missiles and bombs to
stay in power and to keep things the way
they are generally but my question for
mr. mr. Hitchens is with all this talk
about prosecuting perpetrators of
terrorist acts don't we have a history
in this country of reading instruction
manuals on terrorism and distributing
them in Central America and if that's
true or if any of these types of things
are true don't we have people in our own
country like Oliver North that we should
be prosecuting thanks caller well it is
regrettably true that there was a manual
on on terrorism and subversion and
assassination and all of that there was
distributed by not by let's be fair not
by this country you can't say the United
States did this because Congress was not
told about it also the the people who
did it thought highly enough of the
American people at least to have the
grace to lie to them about this but it
is true that such a manual was
circulation given to criminal elements
in Nicaragua with instructions to
proceed to try and destroy the society
and its further true I believe and I
think I could prove if if challenged
that at the so-called school of the
Americas the training school that the
United States government runs for South
America and Central America which is
produced to people like general Noriega
as its graduates methods of of torture
and kidnap and assassination
disappearance were were inculcated on
our diet into these revolting military
elites on which American policies
depended for far too long
so yeah that's undoubtedly true and the
the case I make against Henry Kissinger
was a much broader one than that is that
ever since the arrest of General
Pinochet in London we've entered a new
world where there's such a thing the
common phrase for it now the legal
phrases universal jurisdiction the war
criminal and the I find the word
terrorist a bit vague but let's use it
for now people like that are defined in
laws the common enemies of humanity they
may be arrested and put on trial
wherever they
found and sovereign immunity the claim
that some of them make that well what
they did they did as politicians or as
legally appointed public servants is
false will be struck down by a court
that's not a defense for committing
crimes of torture murder kidnap and the
rest of it so I think it's excellent
I mean mr. Pinochet is on his way to
jail he won't go actually because the
Chileans are very forgiving and he will
be successfully pleaded mental disorder
but he's he's ended his days in diet age
I think possibly General Suharto of
Indonesia will go the same way Henry
Kissinger was hit on body enough on the
10th of September this year in
Washington DC in a federal court with a
suit which will be found to have
standing by the relatives of a Chilean
officer who he had murdered in Santiago
in 1917 it's taken a long time to catch
up with him but the law has a long arm
and a long memory what was your travel
route to Pakistan in Afghanistan well
actually I had it was a guard dog leg
route because I had an appointment in
Calcutta they had to keep first with a
brilliant photographer called sebastio
Salgado
I'm sure some of your audience know he's
a wonderful excuse me
wonderful Brazilian photographer he's
he's basically photographed the third
world he's done exploitation of labor
rape of natural resources refugees
migrants war five or six major albums of
work and he's now the World Health
Organisation's
do excuse me envoi ambassador for the
eradication of polio which he'll be glad
to hear is nearly done now but 2004
probably most countries will report in
the polio has gone and West Bengal was
one of the places where that's been
fought fourth hardest and I went with
phonology fair with him we're going to
do a big portfolio of his pictures on
the or struggling his polio then it was
a real honor to go around Calcutta with
them with such a guy so when I'd done
that I rushed off Rhino jelly to
Islamabad
and then did you drive to the Afghan
border I did but I said well I got
someone to do that for me because I felt
I needed someone who spoke Pashtun how
long did it take
Oh from his knowledge to Peshawar is it
takes you about three hours I would say
it's very near frightening me near in
some ways and when you're in the shower
you're in subways you're in Afghanistan
it's um it's an Afghan town that border
is very wobbly line drawn as you know
it's full of Afghan refugees very very
tense atmosphere at the moment and you
went is that Balliol College Oxford yes
how many colleges comprise Oxford I
think it's about 23 the there's no such
thing as a campus as such it Oxford is
just around the middle of the challenges
wonderful old medieval city the about
yeah upstate now it's it's above 2,000
rule in enclosed buildings close to
buildings each of them self-governing so
you can't there's no such place as
Oxford University really it's a mystery
I we used to laugh it was a favourite
thing
Joker she was American tourists I'm
sorry to say when I was killed we will
you meet us or looking very stranded
wearing Bermuda shorts asking directions
for the University and see where I can't
help you but you can count how to you my
college if you like our next call is
from Oxford this is how we make people
feel at home so you can go ahead caller
how many colleges how many college is at
Oxford is it 23 yeah I don't know I
thought it was 27 actually fair enough
well a couple of new ones since I was
there okay and of course now um girls
can share it all this chip holding
Chelsea Clinton indeed yeah go ahead I'm
sorry tolerance Africa I was at the
meeting of the Oxford University
Historical Society at Bowie all the
other night president just to make you
feel at home very much and I very much
appreciate your writing especially in
Vanity Fair and the other one we goes on
in that magazine which is very good
thank you and I I do wonder a little bit
about the current crisis whether I very
much agree that this is a
two of the secular enlightenment versus
various sorts of fundamentalism and I'm
wondering against that background
whether at least part of the problem is
not the widespread cynicism in the world
about the United States and the role of
moral leadership being given effect you
know President Bush is trying to give
that moral leadership so are other
people in America but that's undermined
consistently by the sorts of issues that
you discussed already the US policies in
South America or Latin America and other
parts of the world and isn't it the case
that's aligned this the United States
has to BRIC join in with the
internationalization of justice and
become a full participant in all those
those activities including the bringing
to justice of war criminals and the
identification of the dead hand of
corporations involved in bringing about
Wars and so on well I'm not completely
out of sympathy with what you say and I
know what I know exactly what you mean
by what you say as well but here's what
I think if there was to be a list of the
top ten
scribblers it was working in Washington
the top ten critics of the u.s. foreign
policy I would hope to have made that
list by now if I didn't make it I would
feel bad and if I was told I was on the
top ten I'd feel like combat honestly
and I think some people watching know
what I mean by that I would yield to
nobody and that's what I meant when I
read the Kissinger book but I don't
think in some sense I don't think this
has anything to do with that the
al-qaeda attack was not on that the
al-qaeda attack was directly on American
civil society the al-qaeda people are
trying to impose fascism on the Muslim
world have succeeded in person getting
one country already they hope to win
their argument in the Muslim world by
bringing it to the streets of the West
this is an unbelievably fierce challenge
therefore as I said earlier it's
impossible for it to succeed Britain can
do a great deal of damage meanwhile
therefore whether President Bush says
he's against it or not should be
irrelevant to you or to me the question
is how against it are you what are you
going to do about it I think to start
the argument by clear
in the throat and taking a step back and
say well let's first deconstruct
American foreign policy would be it
would be a an error I mean those
arguments go on anyway they'll have to
go in anyway I'm not going to change my
side on any of them but it's the
question is do you recognize this as a
challenge to yourself to your own
Society
do you feel solidarity with the other
societies that are being mauled and
profaned by this kind of theocratic
fascism and if so what are you doing to
help them out and builds and intensify
that so I - this is our guest latest
book it's called the art of mentoring
letters to a young contrarian dedicated
to the memory of Peter Sedgwick who is
he
Peter Sedgwick was a man I met just as I
was going to Oxford he was a teacher
there very not a very well-known author
outside his field which was actually
psychiatry and the relationship with
psychiatry - politics
I just I met him when I was about there
must have been 17 or 18 at a meeting
since was staying with that veal town it
was in actually notes for Town Hall it
was a rally against the atrocious war in
Vietnam and I asked a question to some
communist speaker a hostile question and
at the end of the meeting this man came
up to me and so I thought that was a
good argument you had and blah blah and
anyway we became friends and when I went
away to teach which was not long after
that what I was waiting to go to office
fortunate voice goober John in the
Western Peninsula and Devon ship and we
began to correspond and he was very good
he answered all my letters he sent me
books he thought I should really
introduce me to all kinds of subjects
I've been unaware of so I always went
people asked me for advice or if I have
a student who would like some of my time
outside class I always try to do it and
I was trying to think that just payback
Peter who alas is no longer with us
he died appalling Lee Jung and in a very
pointless way next call is Geneva
Switzerland good morning good morning
I'm a big fan of your
and I just took your honesty your
relative you're a clear thought and
honesty as opposed to the dancing as and
my question is about the dancing because
it's just now that we're getting a sense
of what the Al Jazeera Network might be
like and I'm wondering about its funding
and economics and I'm wondering about
the balance that CNN may or may not
provide in the Muslim world for
information and whether or not it makes
sense to set up something like an
infomercial type 24-hour news broadcast
so that Arabs can actually hear other
Arabs and get other information and
points of view that are bent towards
specifically giving them the information
I know they're working on they're
already doing radio but obviously visual
whenever as opportune is always more
impacting and you know the infomercial
there's the mild distortions you know
are only of you know the mild
distortions are only mild in many
respects I'll start there thanks for the
call well I didn't think there was any
mystery about the financing of Al
Jazeera I thought we knew that it was
the Sultan of matter who put up the
dough isn't that correct and it's not I
don't know if that's sinister or or not
I mean it seems nothing covert about it
in any case nothing surreptitious I saw
a very interesting discussion involving
my friend Robert Fisk as one of the
vests of the Middle Eastern reporters if
not the best and some other participants
I think this was actually on the BBC
World Channel which isn't bad
and what Fisk said this was a time when
there was talk of you know not letting
al Jazeera broadcast just straight to us
with mr. bin Laden's remarks Fisk said
well the thing is this he's met this was
met bin Laden more than anyone else ugly
so when he meets been Don he asks him a
lot of
she doesn't just say have you got any
remarks I can carry away with me put in
my newspaper so that your words gets the
rest of the world he's not a megaphone
he's sort of ventriloquist's dummy and
Jazeera does do that who has been doing
that whereas when they interviewed Tony
Blair say or anyone else they're quite
right they asking a lot of tough
questions so what they need to do is
become a great deal more journalistic
and combative and they have to do the
job of asking questions they can't just
be a megaphone next call Philadelphia
for Christopher Hitchens good morning
good morning morning but my question is
the tackle the World Trade Center in
many ways was another Pearl Harbor it
was a sneak attack there had been many
indications before than actual actions
over the intervening 30 years where
Americans have been in fact generally
overseas my question is do you reckon
that it will always be a Pearl Harbor
type of action World Trade Center kind
of action that is required in future to
arouse this country to really address
issues is this the nature of the bond
for season thanks caller if I could pick
up as a segue to what you write into any
Vanity Fair which is more than I worry
about flag waving I worry about what
will happen when the flag waving has to
stop all these ceremonies of emotion
from children's drawings to fun drives
are prone to diminishing returns a time
will come when fewer taxis fly the Stars
and Stripes and it could be just at that
point that another awful wound is
inflicted by cohort and nefarious
enemies covert in a various animation
yeah would you worry about that I also
said that piece that I think Pearl
Harbor is the least useful comparison
I'm sorry to disturb you sir Pearl
Harbor was something that could have
been in was predicted not not the day or
the timing but it was understood that
the United States and Japan will
maneuvering for an advantage in the
Pacific where the empires were going to
clash in the probably the first clash
would be naval the Japanese found a
brilliant way of finessing that there at
least to their opening
and they used their own uniformed fliers
losing many of them in the process to
attack a strictly military base so very
underhanded miserly but it was within
the rules of Imperial imperialistic
warfare by no means the worst thing
that's ever been done by contrast the
forces of al-qaeda used used civilians
as missiles to kill civilians and if
they had succeeded in what they might
have had in mind I believe they could
have had in mind in in New York which so
we have to imagine is that those planes
hit went sharking into the building's
earlier perhaps half an hour later which
is given what we know what takeoff times
are like at Logan Airport in New Jersey
as anyone just try to notice wouldn't
have been at all unthinkable you could
have factored that in the building's
could have been nearly full that's
50,000 people as far as the attackers
now and they might have aimed and hoped
to bring them down not to implode them
but to bring them down sideways make
them fall over so if they fall they're
both a quarter of a mile high even if
they could have hoped to kill 100,000
people in Manhattan rush hour the early
morning that would have been the Dresden
of the Taliban it would not have been a
Pearl Harbor at all go back to calls but
very quickly and this photograph is when
the twin towers were completed and as
you write you first saw them back in the
summer of 1970 when the World Trade
Center was still under construction do
you think they will or should they
rebuild the World Trade Center I would
say that I am one of those things that
would be a bad idea for one thing I
don't think it's possible to build on
that site I'm not a religious person I
believe briefly of the sacrosanct list
of remains I'm going to give my own
carcass to science I've already done so
in fact but I I think everyone has a
natural revulsion against desecration
and this is like Antigone this is the
unburied bodies that in this pool Morris
in the streets I have to even go on that
next call from London for Christopher
Hitchens thanks for taking my call the
traditions
I like your comments especially your
view and opinion on on India's position
in the world in the global economy today
and in the global political scenario
especially your comment about Keeler
pluralistic and democratic approach of
India as I as I compare the status of
Pakistan 3 September 11th and now I
would like your opinion especially when
Pakistan used to be a vermin supporter
of the Taliban and had diplomatic
relations with the Taliban was state
sponsoring terrorism in fact also
calling a general pervez musharraf the
military dictator calling some of the
terrorists who've been banned by the
Western world freedom fighters and now
in the last two months as you compared
the status of Pakistan where now they
are being showered with military aid 28
F 16 just been reallocated to Pakistan
million dollar aid package while some of
the fundamentals still stay the same
very much agree with you and I've been
my forthcoming piece in - affair I
rehearsed a lot of the same misgivings
that I have about current US policy I
think it's far too indulgent to the
Pakistani military oligarchy which is
the problem in the first place mr. Bush
his opening speech said we will make no
distinction if you remember which in the
Taliban and al-qaeda those who harbor
and
harbored them well this is more of the
Pakistani military oligarchy and the
Saudi Arabian ruling family John much
more than harbor al-qaeda the Taliban
they have sponsored incubators and paid
for armed helped and trained them and
install them riveted them upon the the
luckless people of Afghanistan who in
the history of having had some very
depressing governments have never had
anything as horrifying this slavery
penury beggary
destitution that's what they've done to
the afghan people think what they would
do to us so
I thought that I thought and think that
the dependence of the United States
policy or not really owning up to that
because we'd rather say we had Muslim
friends and say what ought to be said
about General Musharraf and the Saudis
in addition to we become prisoners of
our allies and the fragile matter is the
Pakistani army is sabotaging the war
against the Taliban it doesn't want it
to succeed it openly says it doesn't
want it to succeed if you read what it
says carefully it wants to keep as much
of its Afghan assets as it can if it
wants to hold on to a pliable quasar
child abandoning think in Kabul in order
that it retains strategic depth as it
calls it for a confrontation with India
a holy war confrontation as they call it
over Kashmir into which they have
introduced nuclear weapons this is an
unbelievably appalling allied in half
and as I say I have the strongest doubt
that it is anything more than a very
false friend in this battle and I'm
sorry to interrupt you like the book
again and also makes it okay just also
writes for Vanity Fair and the Nation
magazine and we have hyperlink the
nation is part of c-span's website if
you want to log on and find out more
about that publication we'll get a call
from Jensen Beach Florida good morning
and they were going to waive the book
and will waive the book again we're not
doing it enough well that was right no
just you said you were vouchers that is
it I didn't want to step on that line
from step go ahead caller
oh I'm out am I on you are Thank You
c-span
mr. Hitchens Brian lambs not there this
morning so I have to ask you are you
still social yeah and I think I think I
say this in the book um
20 years I've been doing this the show
would very nearly 20 years since it were
since it started and Brian always used
to ask me this look politely politely
incredulity you know he said you were
socialists Wow you know then it became a
habit every time I came back on he'd say
well by the way I haven't checked lately
I used to every time I'd say sure I
would never be pushed off position of
principle like that and I knew that one
day he thought I'll ask him and he'll
say no I've rethought it and then I
started to think I'm not going to give
him the satisfaction so it's probable be
here we come to him it's probable that I
went on saying I was for slightly longer
than
would have done if it wasn't for prime
hand or the paper the brand lamp kept me
a socialist off I actually now for
various reasons I haven't got time for I
don't have political allegiance in
London do I don't have an ideological
one either I spent my entire life on a
Marxist left and I learned a lot from it
and if I could tell you that this quite
a lot about this is in the book about
what I learned what I thought was
worthwhile from it would still defend
but I don't really think there is a
socialist movement I don't think it's
going to revive if I'm really objective
about it but I don't and I don't think
an identikit exists as a platonic
alternative either so I haven't I don't
take back everything I've ever said
about capitalism where he means but I
now ask people I asked off people you
know what are their what are their
principles not not what are their
politics
question hmm this is Islamic holy war
it's been said it it's an attack on on
Western culture isn't it really an
attack on the global culture well at
first it's an attack on Islamic culture
which from which the West's we what we
call Western civilisation is made up
quite largely of contributions from the
Muslim world particularly they are
Muslim world to give I mean the most
salient example would be most of the
writing of the ancient Greek
philosophers of 5th century Athens was
completely lost to the West for many
centuries and was substantially
obliterated in many parts of Europe by
Christianity which didn't want it to be
thought that there had been high wisdom
and high ethics before the coming of
Jesus Christ
so there's but the the works of the
Greeks were preserved in great Muslim
universities and libraries and came back
to the West through through aunt Elyssa
through Spain we are them that we you
try and do thermodynamic calculations
using Roman numerals and see where you
get or any other kind of calculation the
the numerals are from the Muslim wealth
Geneva Switzerland now so wait this
isn't but the societies that did that
the Muslim societies that allowed these
tremendous achievements were open and as
you can see were interested in things
like the Greeks and things like the Jews
and things I do succeed in in
discussions with Judaism the al-qaeda
Taliban
Audiology would make that kind of Muslim
cultural life impossible and remember
before they blew up the World Trade
Center
they used heavy artillery to blow up the
two big statues of Buddha in Bamian and
Afghanistan they mean business they want
total cultural arisia obliteration of
culture science free inquiry separation
of church and state emancipation of
women all the things that make
civilization possible they are
determined to destroy that's an attack
on the Muslim world
go ahead Geneva good morning good
morning I'm recording from Geneva my
question is to the speaker here we know
I heard somewhere that every Napoleon
has his Waterloo or every Weddington has
his Waterloo what am I trying to say was
the World Trade Center attack in interp
meant by which al-qaeda called in Russia
to enter there water looked whether the
government in Afghanistan if I got the
question right I think the question is
asking was asking was that is this some
kind of a trap it was the was the hope
that Bush was the hope of the murderers
the fanatics to entice President Bush to
involve himself in Afghanistan I don't
think I don't think so
but let's suppose it's true I wouldn't
think it was such a grave matter I'll
tell you why excuse me I'm sorry for my
throat this morning in a June of this
year I was very proud to say I was asked
by a group of from American and Afghan
female scholars if I put my name on a
petition to be circulated around
Washington and elsewhere
demanding that the United States
government disown the Taliban as the
government of Afghanistan as it looked
them because the Taliban was the
creation of our lovely Pakistani allies
and their military secret police the ISI
the United States had no real beef with
the Taliban regime we thought we should
change that I still believe that mr.
Bush is not sufficiently anti-taliban I
would instance the following the
Revolutionary Association of women of
Afghanistan rawa as it's called our HR
anyway has a real network of opposition
and resistance in Kabul and Kandahar
Civic opposition they are able to get
reporters in and out a wonderful film
which you may have seen called behind
the veil was made with their assistance
they're a real force they've never been
invited to any of these broad-based
government meetings that you hear about
from the administration
why not the Pakistani army doesn't like
rawa and the Saudis don't want to see
women in meetings sponsored by the
United States about future government of
Afghanistan so 50% of the population is
supposed to be kept out of the picture
so you hear that the the report is
saying another meeting today of the
future broad-based government and it's a
narrow group of elderly men in turbans
who represent feudal clans and or the
absurd claim of the Exile monarchy well
this is not good enough so you know I
think Bush should have been more
anti-taliban much earlier and I hope he
gets even more onto table and very soon
next call long beach island good morning
good morning you guys c-span a one job
Saudi mr. Hitchens I've got a little
wild question I think that this all
revolves around religion and how this
the different religious or the world
since the beginning of the written word
have impact our society that have fused
their doctrine on us and taken apart our
way of us thought that of free speaking
individuals here in America how do you
feel about that mr. it I think I think
if you and I met we pull really fun so
we thought was very much like I'm a
large part of my book is an attack on
faith I mean I think with people say I
have faith but I don't know why they
expect me to be impressed what that
means is that they rely on something
they couldn't prove and can't defend in
argument they say it's so because I kind
of believe it I couldn't be less
impressed civilization begins where
where reason kicks in and where there
are there are no unexamined assumptions
where skepticism occurs and out and
experiment begins of where science
begins and medicine and anything else
that's any good for you belief the
belief that you are the plaything of a
creator that you attribute your presence
here not to the laws of evolution and of
biology and physics but to some plan is
I think a horrible idea because I'm glad
it's not true some atheists say they
wish religion was true it's just a shame
it's not I'm not one of those I think
it's a horrible scheme imagine the idea
that you have cradle to grave
supervision the daughter goes on after
you're dead you never get away with it
it's like living in a celestial North
Korea it's impossible to escape it's
demanding that you be enslaved and by
totalizing force
well I'm very very glad that there's no
reason to believe that social force
exists Manchester England for
Christopher Hitchens good one hello mr.
Jones I just like your take on the
Middle East I'd like you to know what
you think of Ariel Huron I mean he's
been responsible for the 1982 massacre
of the Palestinians in Sabra and Shatila
and do you not think there is a
comparison between what the Israelis are
doing today to the Palestinians in the
occupied territories and to what the
Nazis did to the Jews back in the second
Second World War did what's your
question reverse no the last bit I don't
think it's remotely comparable and I
think anyone who studied the history of
German Imperial and Nazi imperialism in
the ladies and 40s in Europe would
recognize Israeli behavior in that
unbelievable campaign to destroy Western
civilization
but you're hearing this said firmly I
hope by someone who who thinks that you
just understated matters about Muriel
Charan here wasn't just responsible for
a massacre of thousands of unarmed
civilians and directly responsible he
instigated it
in 1982 he's been responsible for
massacres and the bullying of killing
civilians all his life he's a religious
thug and one of the worst combinations
imaginable a religious nationalist of
combine once you can buy an ethnicity
with messiaen ISM it doesn't matter
which the religion is you're going to
have a nightmarish result I say this as
someone of Jewish parentage as someone
who actually doesn't think Zionism is a
false messiah for the Jews but we can't
let's not get into all that now it's
it's certainly nothing but pain for the
for the Arabs of Palestine I think their
treatment is appalling and I think they
should have had a state of their own a
long time ago even the Balfour
Declaration which founds the moral
conditions for the Zionist state says
that if that the rights given to Jews in
Palestine must be what's the word
matched by the rights given to the watch
is called growth intensity of the native
population well I certainly am not
prepared to demand as a Jew that an Arab
born in Palestine has should have less
rights there than I born in Portsmouth
as it happens should have Oh indeed I
think it's very dubious that I should
have the same rights as a Jew in
Palestine as someone who was born there
when I wasn't so if you get your foot if
you follow me I therefore shorten this
but I think I think it is an absolute
disgrace that a single cent of American
taxpayers money is allowed to be used by
Israel for the occupation I think they
should stop immediately I think they
Charan should be told if you go Q PI
these people and treat them like cattle
and then threatened to expel them again
to ethnically cleanse them which is
theirs now openly being this one you do
that on your own dime you do not use a
single American weapon or dollar for
that if I was I think he should be told
to stop talking that way in any case
couple minutes left with Christopher
Hitchens first Charleston South Carolina
good morning
yes the morning am I'm a fellow Brit
that can tell absolutely I think we're
about the same age also I'm just
wondering uh what is that
you're I'm glad you asked it not me I
can't I can't no class I'll just leave
that over suspect often wonder how old I
seems and what I just wonder what you
feel about the British role in this at
them in the past generations because
it's a much inflamed this region what
what do you feel that we possibly can do
is rather a poor nation today with Tony
oh don't be so modest um and also just
what did he study at videos I studied
philosophy politics and economics did I
get that question quite right
how would you size up Tony Blair oh well
I don't come even when I am no longer
remember that they were party but when I
was uh I was not on the same wing as the
one that's produced him but I very much
admire the way he's handled himself
recently I thought I'll give it one
example of what I mean as you know quite
a lot of our fellow my fellow Englishmen
and women were killed in that atrocity
we don't know how many but it's quite a
lot more than has ever been killed by
that kind of thing at one time before in
say Belfast or if the other tussles
Blair has made almost nothing of this he
hasn't said we have been talking to the
British public at least the first few
times and when addressing the Labour
Party conference keynote speech he
didn't try and appeal to people saying
look by the way a lot of Brits were
killed too so it's our fighting to find
it quite correctly as something that
quite transcends or ethnic national and
other sorts of boundary I know I admire
him for it I also admire him for
pressing on mr. Bush the following mr.
Bush cannot go around talking about
defending civilization while saying by
the way we don't think this cause of
civilization is good enough to actually
risk an American soldier in can't we
hire some local nurse and residue the
for us or can't we have pilots flying so
high their planes can't be seen or heard
from the ground which pretty much
guarantees there will be bad bombings on
the ground this bad near-miss isn't and
Lavinia misses I mean collateral Janet
Journey blessed is known the SAS people
saying we know we should we should have
already established a fire base right in
the middle of Taliban territory I've
told them we're in your grid square as
the British later point what are you
going to do about that that would put
the fear of the Living God into them if
anything would so I mean I go no I take
my hat off to bear really London go
ahead please thanks for taking my call
mr. Hitchens I'm a big fan although I
may not always agree with my cousin
someone who hates me call up we will be
Fanfan fern all that I'm supposed to be
a worry I'm supposed to be here selling
a book on how to be a contrarian well me
being love bomb doors I was nauseating
but my question is is that you have
advocated the establishment of closer
relationship with India me the BJP
government of India has come to power by
founding Hindu fanaticism missions are
being killed in that country Indian
brutality and Kashmir has gone widely
unreported India has fought Wars with
most of its neighbors or interfered in
the internal affairs of most of its
neighbors like Sri Lanka where it has
supported the Tamil Tigers India even
opposed the UN resolution on East Timor
India opposes the Kashmiri people in
having a stage where Kashmir should go
to either Pakistan or as an independent
Kashmiri state yeah I know I know where
you'll go and I see where you're coming
from some of that is true I'm setting
all the fan of the BJP government
by the Arrogant claims made by Muslim
extremists you know these religious wars
feed off each other's mad theologies
it's also true I must say that I like us
I'm happy with the Indian policy on
Kashmir my my feeling of friendship for
India and Indians comes from this when
you're there you realize that okay the
BJP is in power now it won't be in power
all the time
it isn't in power in many of the states
that make up India's not in power and in
West Bengal's I'm applying Kerala Assad
in power a number of other places the
India's pluralistic it has a secular
Constitution it has seats in its
Parliament for all minorities and it has
extraordinary achievement I think of
combining democracy secularism and
pluralism great strain but well worth
defending and I think if it was to make
more friends the the odds are that end
of the scale would go up is that what I
want to dress up and the other end of
the scale would go down the more
depressing things that you mentioned on
Kashmir listen no Indian is completely
happy with the way that kashmiris
girlfriend but it is the fact that in
1977 there was an election in Kashmir it
was endorsed by Sheikh Abdullah
the leader of the Muslims of Kashmir the
charismatic leader of Islam in and it
did not vote for Pakistan so I don't
believe that I believe it would if there
was another election but in the meantime
Pakistan has absolutely no right to be
arming and training and dispatching
across the border the forces of mr. bin
Laden who nearly blew up the Parliament
the other day killing a lot of people in
the attempt to throw acid in the faces
of Indian women telling them to drop the
veil not having any of that Los Angeles
for Christopher Hitchens good morning
great I like your type type of argument
you basically have intellectual
discussion instead of a screaming
argument I'm a I'm a libertarian please
on the opposite side of the spectrum of
you but a wonder if she could clarify a
couple things for me I believe Palestine
was the entire area covering Israel and
Jordan I wonder if you could tell me at
what point the Palestinians went to
Jordan and I realize they were kicked
out when they blew up some passenger
jets or something and I are you familiar
with that oh yes I think more than you
are by the sound of it
oh sure others well go ahead basically
revolves around the Palestinians that
were from Israel I don't understand the
there's 22 Arab states why they have to
take over Israel uh-huh
what are 49 American states if someone
told you you couldn't tell from the one
you're sitting in if someone told you
actually we would rather have your bit
of Los Angeles for ourselves from now on
this would only be this you really be a
land holder or a house holder here if
you profess the let's say Muslim or
Buddhist faith otherwise get out this
bit SARS you're happy to go to Colorado
on that basis I don't think so and I
think if you think about it you wouldn't
insult anyone else about treating them
their society or their country as as
disposable as that the Palestinians do
not feel that God gave the land to
someone else and they therefore have to
be flung out and I completely agree with
them the they've every right to resist
that ridiculous proposal are the way
could I just say that if you if you say
or a libertarian
though I must say you sound like an aura
sharing with Palestinian second son if
you are in a Bashar and you may find
some nourishment in my book where I say
that in the same breath as I as I mourn
the decay of some of my socialist
allegiances that deep down remember I've
always been a sympathizer of the
libertarian anti state his point of view
and one of the things that our tragedy
socialism the beginning was the idea of
the withering width stayed hey well you
might get some amusement up it keeps
coming back to the book you've got a way
to promote it this is America own
message last call from Leeds England for
Christopher Hitchens we have about a
minute left go ahead please College
another big flutter you work
not again I read a brief serialization
of your novel in The Guardian yesterday
it read like a novel did it that's nice
it's the same book wrong word I
apologize
No do you still have hope in the face of
all this religious intolerance which I
see on a local basis living among Muslim
communities young Muslim youth and then
on a global reach there's a lot of
religious intolerance it's very easy to
portray that as coming from the Islamic
side of the world the law obviously it's
both sides do you still have hope is
this not fair like Clash of
Civilizations my view about that is it
isn't a clash of civilizations no
because there's too much civilization on
what people would otherwise call the
other side and Muslim side but there is
that there's a very big clash of
worldviews and it's a fight which I
personally think it's absolutely
essential to have it look the
alternative of not fighting it does not
exist you can't surrender to theocratic
fascism nor could you live or coexist
with it so that's easy and if it's since
they make it a choice them or us it'll
be them will make absolutely sure of it
this is what the book looks like the
letters to a young contrarian the author
is Christopher Hitchens what's your next
project um in the year 2003 it will be
the centennial of George Orwell sent a
note for George Orwell's birth and I've
written a book which will come out in
the middle of next year saying why I
think he was one of the most important
writers of the 20th century it should be
should be honored again so I think it's
we haven't got a title yet with
originally it's called the victory of
George Orwell we thank you for joining
us come back again it was a pleasure
thank you by the way c-span made a
mistake and we want to correct it in our
coverage of the UN General Assembly
which by the way was originally
scheduled to meet in late September
postponed because of the events of
September the 11th and meeting
throughout the next week we had
misidentified one of the speakers it was
South Korean Prime Minister Lee Han dong
we had identified him as the North
Korean prime minister he of course is
the South Korean Prime Minister we
apologize for that mr.
can we thank our audience for letting us
know about that speaking of c-span
coverage of the events in New York City
and on this Veterans Day here in
Washington and Arlington National
Cemetery Vice President Dick Cheney will
be among the speakers our live coverage
will get underway in about 25 minutes
with the musical interlude and the
remarks getting underway at 11 o'clock
President Bush is at the site of the
World Trade Center for a ceremony that
will take place this afternoon at 1:30
East Coast time 10:30 for those of you
in the West Coast and we'll have live
coverage of that again here on c-span
don't forget to check out American
politics tonight which will include Karl
Rove who spoke to a conservative group
here this past Thursday and Senator Joe
Lieberman who was up in Manchester New
Hampshire speaking to New Hampshire
Democrats that's American politics and
booknotes the topic tonight is a new
book Roosevelt's secret war followed by
Prime Minister's Questions which is seen
tonight at 9:00 Eastern six o'clock for
those of you in the West Coast and Peter
Bergen who is out with a book called
holy war Incorporated
we'll be here tomorrow morning to take
your calls his book by the way is
previewed in the Washington Post book
section today and a reminder on c-span 2
what's your last advantage now this week
it is No thank you great book great the
great issue of magazine - the book
that's ok Judith Miller's book germs
biological weapons at America's secret
war you can watch her tonight at 7:30
Eastern Time she is in New York at the
92nd Street Y all part of c-span's book
TV coverage